[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i'm standing outside
the worst property that i ever bought
now this was a no money down deal
i did it as part of a joint venture
agreement and there's someone
somewhere out there that owns part of
this house with me hey if you're
watching and you want it back
have it back have it and i'll tell you
why it's bad on so many levels
people's biggest fear when they buy a
house is what if they can't rent the
house out and then they're not making
any money from it well this property
it's it's bad it's been trashed and
right now it's empty
and you can see that it's empty because
there's about three months worth of post
on the floor but you know what
whilst it's empty which is a really bad
thing normally i would
i would be absolutely devastated that i
had an empty house
and this is how bad this has got i'm
actually glad that it's empty
because previously to it being empty
there was a tenant in here
that wasn't paying rent and they were
wearing the house down
and there's only one thing worse than no
tenant
and that's a bad tenant so this is the
lounge
such a big lounge but and it was worse
than this
this is after someone has cleared out
all the junk and the rubbish
and it's so shabby
it just needs a sense of life all the
things that people are like
what if this happens what if that
happens all the things that could
possibly go wrong
has gone wrong with this house so let's
go and have a look around
so it's got two reception rooms this
second reception room can't be used as a
bedroom
i know people say but samuel you say if
it's the second reception room put a bed
on it and rent it out as a bedroom and
do it as a hmo
it's not in the right area for hmos i
remember when i first got this
i remember i remember thinking about the
garden well because it's slabbed it's
going to be low maintenance because the
grass won't be able to grow because
there is no grass
little did i know that the weaves would
grow instead
and it does need maintenance after all
now this kitchen i got this kitchen
brand spanking new i spent about
three and a half thousand pound getting
this new kitchen and now
three years later it almost looks like
it needs a new kitchen
again i don't think it does i reckon
maybe a real good
scrub but it's just depressing you know
it's it's demoralizing
imagine this imagine you're a tenant and
you leave the house would you
really leave things like a
dirty sock on the floor
surrounded by mud that i hope is mud
this was a brand new oven like
three years ago it was it looked so good
it was so
clean now i'm scared to even open the
oven
i shouldn't be i shouldn't be scared
should i should i be scared to open
an oven my oven in my house but i just i
just
know
oh my goodness
how how does this happen i mean it's
like a volcano of grease
if someone said to me samuel you've got
you've got two weeks and you need to
make a nice clean oven look like this
i wouldn't know where to start i've been
how do you make an oven
this disgusting like ah
how how does this happen i mean maybe
the sock was left on the floor and the
dirt because they left in a hurry and
they had kids and
things but the thing that just freaks me
out is like what why
why would someone climb up on a chair
and remove
and leave it like this dangerous with
wires and
like why why why would you do this to my
house
what we who who and this who just
who breaks a light switch like this how
how does this happen tell me bad tenants
how the sock i understand but this
and this this kind of i don't i don't
get that
jeez
i get free freaked out when my kids just
draw on the wall a little bit i'm like
oh my gosh you know i'll put it right
immediately
um the drawing on the wall
[Laughter]
looks like that that's the best bit of
wall in the house there
there's like cobwebs everywhere
i've just literally got back from the
castle and
the attic of my castle there's bats in
it i was in there with the bats
and it was less than that cupboard
just saying i'm hoping that upstairs
is a little bit better than downstairs
so far
it's okay it's okay
okay this room isn't too bad
oh damp
and weird electrical things
this is not how this was talented okay
we didn't rent this out like this
we didn't rent this out like this and
maybe you might be thinking
but samuel it's not the tenant's fault
that the property got damp
or maybe the tenant didn't have that
maybe his head down because he's been
empty a little while
fair enough maybe we should give the
tenant the benefit of the doubt but
here's the thing
okay here's the thing properties
generally speaking have damp as a result
of how you live in the house like i have
tenants contact me and say
oh samuel there's damp there's damp and
i'll normally say to them things like
have you opened the windows when you're
showering and they're like what
have you and i'll go through a few
questions with them one of the questions
i asked them is
um did your last house have damp and
they go yeah
dude how about the house before yeah it
just seems that every one of my houses
has damp
do you think there's a common
denominator here do you think it could
be because of something you're doing
now maybe you think i mean harsh maybe
think something you've been super harsh
but by the way
i judge the oven and the cooking of the
tenant that lived in this house
i don't think i've been harsh to say
that this
is possibly a result of not opening
windows
having really long showers and just
generally being a terrible tenant oh man
i i'm not feeling
i am not feeling in a happy mood right
now i'm
genuinely considering giving this house
away
for free to somebody if there wasn't
such a high mortgage that's another
thing this house is it's got no equity
in it so i can't even give it away for
free
probably the best room in the house
based on how broken everything is in the
house
i don't fancy risking this ladder
working and me falling down and breaking
my legs so i'm not gonna go up there
let's see the second bedroom
okay see this isn't too bad it's just
filthy
it's just absolutely filthy but i think
with a good clean
this could be a very average room
i mean the best thing about this this
room is the view
the view is fantastic and the best part
of the view
is looking at my nice range rover parked
outside
now generally the view is pretty pretty
good the view is pretty good
bedroom three
oh geez okay
so more damn wallpaper is going to come
off completely which probably means then
we're going to need to re-plaster
this is getting a little bit expensive
all i would estimate this whole reefer
would probably be at least 4
000 pound and that's gonna be not even
to a super super high standard
that would be my that would be my yes
which takes away
about well i would say it takes away
about 10 years profit but as i haven't
made any profit over the last 10 years
it's it's worse than that okay
next this is room number four slash
room number three and a half tiny little
cup office room
but i mean to be fair it's a big house i
used to wonder why the insurance was so
expensive on this house this
is so big so this room
yeah same story not great
just the same shabby self as the rest of
the house and the bathroom
it honestly feels like looking at the
toilet how disgustingly dirty
how rusty everything is it looks like
this house hasn't been lived in
for at least a year or two but
but that's not the case i just
the thing is if this house had gone up
in value like crazy if this house was
now worth
two hundred thousand i bought it for
around about a hundred thousand i
probably wouldn't be so upset because i
think
at least it's gone up in value the thing
is i haven't got capital's appreciation
and i can't really help that you win
some you lose some maybe it will go up
in the future but what i can control is
the fact that
i'm here right now see you shouldn't
have to be that's people's biggest fear
is if i buy far away from home and i
have to end up being there but i'm here
but the reason i'm here in fact the
reason for all of these things could be
solved by one thing and this is the
lesson in this it's the lesson for me
the lesson for you get a good letting
agent that's it
because if that's a good letting agent i
wouldn't be here right now i wouldn't be
whinging doing this video because
there'd be a tenant it'll be nice
also if there was a good letting agent i
wouldn't have it trashed because a
letting agent would
check the property regularly and make
sure that there was being inspections
done if there was a good letting agent
on it
it would mean that there would be rent
being paid because they'd vet the tenant
and they'd ask the tenant the right
questions do the right checks see the
laying agent i had on this
i've had previously has been 35 minutes
away from the house
so they're not so incentivized because
it's a bit far for them they've always
taken quick fast tenants
rather than choosing quality tenants so
i've just been with a letting agent
today she reckons she can rent this
thing out for about five to five
nice lady from be my home i think the
company was called
seems to have a lot of experience
located five minutes down the road
so that's what you want so my lesson is
and because i've not got
lots of houses in this area i wasn't
really incentivized to spend time
finding the right agent but if you spend
time finding the right agent
then they'll spend time finding the
right tenants and if you look after the
agent
they'll look after the tenants so my
problem here has
all been tenant related and i haven't
been dealing with attendance the agent
has
so the key is to get a good
tenant manager and most of my properties
are working like clockwork this is not
normal but another thing is
expect problems because you are going to
have some bad houses if you have lots of
houses
it's not realistic to expect them all to
be going like clockwork
making good money going up in value
you're gonna have some bad ones and you
have to look at your portfolio as a
whole
anyway that's it i hope you enjoyed the
video i know i didn't enjoy making it
i've not enjoyed any of this
but if you want to learn more about
property then please do subscribe to the
channel if you want to see more videos
in fact if you want to see the five top
ways that i've lost money in property
it's a little bit of a negative video
again but you need to learn the negative
as well as the positive so that you can
make the right choices and make the
right decisions in property you want to
watch that video check it out right
here that was cool that was the best
part of the video right also don't
forget to subscribe do that right here
honestly if you don't subscribe to the
channel right now and turn the
notification bell on right here you're
going to end up with
houses just like this so subscribe right
now otherwise you'll be doomed forever
see you next time
[Music]